Republican congresswoman Liz Cheney has
sort of had enough with some of her
Republican colleagues she's saying to
them hey we've just got to denounce this
white supremacy we've got to denounce
this great replacement Theory stuff we
need to actually
forcefully not in a mealy mouth than
equivocating way we just need to
denounce the stuff that has been coming
from our side that is in the Buffalo
Shooters Manifesto and this makes her
slightly less crazy than other
Republicans but it doesn't make her a
political Ally that's an important thing
to remember so let's talk this through
Liz Cheney has reportedly uh said now
that Republican house leaders need to
renounce the insanity that is sort of
tied up with what the a buffalo shooter
said Liz Cheney echoed a growing chorus
that Saturday's race targeted massacre
in Buffalo New York was a product of
rhetoric pushed by Republican leaders
let's look at the tweet that she sent
where she said the house Republican
leadership has enabled white nationalism
white supremacy and anti-Semitism that's
correct
list Cheney is right she went on to say
history has taught us that what begins
with words ends in far worse and of
course that's what we saw in Buffalo
over the weekend going on to say
republican leaders must renounce and
reject these views and those who hold
them it's not enough just to say that
you're against violence and that you're
against what the shooter did and that
you're against targeting of black people
the way the shooter did you you can't
just kind of pick around the edges at
the issue Liz Cheney is accurately
saying we have to forcefully say there
is simply no place for white nationalism
white supremacy and anti-Semitism in the
Republican party that's what undergirds
the manifesto and the shooting that took
place in Buffalo over the weekend and
Republican leaders at least so far have
not been willing to say that now I think
it's important when we talk about Liz
Cheney in these terms to remind you how
low the bar is Liz Cheney is a complete
and total trumpist by policy well hold
on what do you mean David well if you
look at 538's tracking of Liz Cheney
they found that in her career Liz Cheney
voted 93
with Donald Trump's position okay 93
with Donald Trump's position during the
115th Congress it was 96 during the
116th Congress it was you know 92.8
percent she almost always is aligned
with Trump Trump or was When Donald
Trump was President so this is not a
political Ally sometimes I say these are
not our friends and some people get mad
and they write in and say David that's
divisive language we can all be friends
maybe okay maybe we can be friends maybe
not just forget about that these are not
political allies yes Liz Cheney said
Trump was responsible for inciting the
Insurrection okay that that doesn't make
her a political Ally that just means
she's marginally willing to tell the
truth about obvious things Liz Cheney uh
has said Donald Trump really lost the
election it wasn't stolen by Joe Biden
Trump just lost that's it it doesn't
make her a political Ally 93 of the time
she still voted with Donald Trump during
her career and at the end of the day
that's really how we evaluate uh
someone's political perspective so she's
absolutely right she's correctly
pointing out that the Republican
leadership has been mealy mouth and
unwilling to sort of in a full-throated
way just denounce the way that this
radical ideology has pervaded the
Republican party in right-wing media
she's completely correct but she still
voted the way Trump did uh Trump in line
with Trump's positions
93 of the time so it's just a reminder
what do we do with that information okay
it's a reminder that as we think about
who do we need in power to achieve
change it's not going to be slightly
less wacky Republicans like Liz Cheney
that's not worth the future
of the left in the United States is it's
it's not going to be we can't count on
her uh it's also not going to be center
right Democrats like Joe manchin uh we
just have to be realistic about that
that's the point I'm trying to make here
and Liz Cheney good for her let's see if
the Republican Party listens to her they
don't seem to care about what she has to
say and let's see if they actually come
out in in a full-throated way denounce
this ideology that is all over the
Buffalo shooting